I think that what we're gonna see in
through Coppa 19 and the crisis and what
I think is gonna happen to the economy
which is is gonna be less an ideal it's
gonna be somewhere between less than
ideal and catastrophic and so I think
what the people who are going to win are
the people that are gonna be able to
start over and one thing that you've
talked a lot about you certainly talked
about in your newest book traffic
secrets is understanding that look some
things could just go away overnight
and how you respond to that is going to
be really really essential so what's the
role of discipline in your life how can
people get more of it in their own lives
yeah I think now I've been thinking a
lot about it cuz I have you know
obviously I helped work the huge
entrepreneur community of entrepreneurs
and like a lot of them are freaking out
right now for you know all the all the
normal reasons and what's been
interesting is watching a lot of them
who just have like frozen up right now
where it's like I don't know what to do
and as I work them to talk through with
with a whole bunch of them it's like
understanding that so many of them are
so scared of like failure so scared of
whatever the next thing is but they
never they're not willing to like to
take the step so there's frozen which is
like the worst the worst possible thing
and I think one of the most valuable
things I got out of wrestling that that
ties back to this was like when you're
wrestling you step on the mat and when
you lose it's like I lost this match but
it'll never sounds like I'm a loser that
like I lost this match let me go figure
out what I need to do to win next time
whereas it seems like the business so
many people have it tied to their
identity into their to everything that
when they lose that they say I'm a loser
it's because of that like they're scared
to lose they don't want to feel like a
loser they're scared of you know maybe
they have a dream or a vision they're
scared that if they try to fails that
the dream will disappear and I think I
think the biggest thing this helped me
throughout this I think that I think
most people need to have is just is
going in with the expectation of like
it's okay if I lose this K if I fail
like it doesn't mean I'm afeeling means
like this the situation failed but then
when you detach yourself from that then
it's so much easier to be like okay what
was wrong what I need to tweak and go
out and try it again and try it again
and try it again because so many people
were just so frozen right now and I
think that's the that's the biggest
thing I thing with mindset is just
helping people to detach
the consequences of the failure being
their own it and as opposed to failure
being being like a match like the thing
that just that failed that you can go
back and fix and and figure out the next
step with that makes sense I think that
people people are gonna face fatigue in
this like the having to get up and try
and try and try again if they've lost
their job the thought of rebuilding
imagine somebody in their 50s losing
their job now and they're like you know
I've got to rebuild like I'm tired the
thought of having to start from
scratches is bordering on unbearable
what what did you discover about
yourself about the human animal in in
building up that kind of conditioning
where it's all on the line dude
everybody is watching you you're there
in the middle of a ring you were
literally in a skin-tight outfit dude
there isn't nowhere to hide and you've
got to pull it out like ah one thing
that to meet the ability to suffer is
one of the most powerful things that an
entrepreneur can build translate that
for me from from the physical to the
business world yeah
man the story I popped my head we start
saying that was I remember it was in
high school I remember which year was
but I remember um you know every single
every single week way to cut weights we
come in I weigh like 160 on Monday
morning and I'd be 130 by Thursday right
so it's like every more do you come
every week you come in oh so you put the
plastics on in the sweats on and all
this stuff you start running cutting
wait I remember is after like a really
really hard practice hadn't eaten or
drinking much that whole week and just
beat up and remember our coach pulled us
all onto this like dark hallway kind of
behind the gym and he had this
conversation with us about attitude and
I remember I remember the whole
conversation I'm saying they're like
like no matter what happens you're gonna
make way no matter what happens it's
gonna suck no matter what happens like
you have to go through this process so
that you can you can really affect is
your attitude so you can have a good
attitude or bad attitude I remember that
night laying there in bed just thinking
like like you I have been having the
worst attitude if I'm hungry I'm thirsty
I'm tired I'm worn out
and I remember the next day I came in I
put my sweats on my plastics on put
everything on you know and before
everyone show up I was out there jump
roping and I just thought I'm gonna have
a smile on my face and like the biggest
smile I possibly can have and so I
started to smile and also my teammates
start coming in and they're all like
just you know like how I felt but I was
like I smiling I'm joke
right brunson why are you so happy why
are you smiling and I remember all I
said I the thing popped my head I was
like I don't know but I've never seen
someone lose with a smile on their face
so I'm gonna smile from now on and I
just you know chills and so that became
a thing and my other team a started
doing that when we come out there and we
would like as the more pain it was like
we would for the smile on like just keep
doing cuz I've never seen someone loses
a smile on their face and so that's
something that you know cuz I mean I've
been in business now this is my 17th
year and there has been like the ups and
the downs there's been you would build a
company with the hundred some employees
and then like one day coming in and
laying off 80 people overnight and then
you know the same thing you know the the
cycles have happened multiple times and
I remember that feeling coming in where
it's just like you've got to lay off 30
people today and then you got a
concealer 50 that like they got to keep
working and there's a vision and there's
a mission and like remember thinking
that a couple times from just like god I
got I don't know if I even believe it
anymore I'm so tired and beat down and
everything seems so heavy and that it
was like but if I don't come in with a
smile like that that's it right and and
you can't lose with a smile on your face
so we come in and we regroup and we talk
about again then we get back to working
and keep going I've made a conscious
effort to make sure I'm more productive
during the corona than before I think
why everyone's sitting down sleeping
that's the time they've read it up you
know so while people can't move they
frozen I'm throw it out and you're
working so the gallery is clicking
we got comedians in there right now in a
safe way and you know we get it in
and I just feel like everybody should do
that you know saying not the same every
day so I don't wanna sound redundant but
I do want to remind everybody so first
thing when I wake up you know actually
see my nose looking at scripts
supporting the look escapes I'm planning
my next moves you know I don't think
things are gonna be back to normal and
that's okay
so I'm planning and preparing for what
the new normal is you know it's time to
strategize it's a plan and to fight you
know this is a war then you got to
figure out what the fight is the
mentality of anyone around me what you
get around me is to be a billionaire or
nothing and that's why you've noticed
the people that they talk about the
hip-hop that a billion is their
mentality it's consistent you know if
you think you can be a billionaire you
can be one you know I'm saying but you
just have to have a product to sell the
product got to be good you got to know
how to package it distribute it collect
your bread and do it all over again
consistently you know some people could
do it on their own as some people need
partners some people couldn't like you
know generate a billion dollars for
businesses some people that own a
billion dollars just be really working
but you got to be doing something that
people would pay with paying for I don't
know too many jobs that pay that you
know so for me you know being younger I
made a million dollars legally very
fairly quickly and I was like this is
kind of easy so I don't know about
everybody else but just based on where I
was at the time it was like damn I made
a me invalid this quick I gotta get more
and I honestly I won't feel I won't feel
satisfied personally unless I'm able to
achieve achieve these dreams on my own
you know and that's my dream is to do it
independently just so that I could pass
it to my daughter and my
and my other daughters you know my other
daughter you know that they they're
doing what they want you know Ava wants
the model right now am i with it but she
ever wants to run the company she could
I just feel like if you had you're on a
purpose if you have nothing to fight for
III wouldn't even understand that
existence you know fan I really wouldn't
have you ever wondered why the Scripps
National Spelling Bee is basically
completely dominated by Indian people
for the last thirty years including well
I didn't make it to that level but I was
number nine in Northern California how'd
that happen
tonight we we really pull back and
understand what makes a top performer a
top performer is it luck
is it genetics or is there something
else going well let's let's try to
answer the question of why am I so good
at spelling let me tell you the
politically correct answer which would
be something like ha I was just
fortunate to be blessed with this skill
I don't really know and you know the
truth is I'm not really good at a lot of
other things so I guess it's just lucky
that I found this one thing that's what
most would say what if you pried the
truth what if you actually got that your
truth might go something like this
when I came home in sixth grade I would
grab a snack and then my mom would open
up a spelling look literally a book with
words and she would quiz me for about
two hours how about that is something
that you don't hear people talk about
and whether you are a top performer at
spelling at fitness at parenting
you never hear people admitting what
they actually do to achieve those
results instead you should just follow
your passion
said every commencement speaker
meanwhile one thing they obscured and
neglected to mention was they spent
literally thousands of hours trial and
error making mistakes learning from
mentors teachers advisers dedicating
themselves to the craft and they finally
became masters i well for those of you
sitting at home right now you can either
be the best opportunity for the worst of
times
I've been broke many times in my life
and I can talk about being homeless no
money alone for two weeks on a week on
two dollars and she learned to eat pizza
or tacos or something but those are all
growing experiences so being an
entrepreneur is risky you fail a lot and
all that looks like a baby falling down
eventually they started to walk and then
once the baby starts to walk you want to
bicycle a car than a fighter jet you
know that's that's evolution as
transformation so really that's really
what we stand for it rich debt it's not
about job security and working at a job
you hate but it's really being
challenged enjoying it making mistakes
and the big thing is who our friends are
our friends our advisors my accountants
my attorney my bankers and all this we
have different friends
best friend is my account not my best
about but in a closest advisor is my
account because always tax then
customized yes Tom we all right well tax
free well and there's Garret something's
my corporate counsel I don't want to
break the law because the laws are
different tax laws are different you
know employees pay about 40% in taxed
essence play about 60% in tax big
business guys pay about 20% tax and ice
paid zero I don't want to break the law
because I don't want to go to jail and
tap dance and be somebody's boyfriend
you know I don't want to break the law
it's a lot of the things I do are
different than what an employee in a
self-employed person and do so you gotta
have a great attorney also I have a
bookkeeper a real bookkeeper when I meet
an S like at this small and smart but I
mean and asked I say my husband does my
boss or my wife does my books I'm out
because the numbers - probably
inaccurate I've got to have accurate
numbers and what those accurate numbers
I can give them to my accountants and my
attorneys see what that numbers you get
bad bad results so it's all of those
things that are different
you see and the reason I'm happy you
guys are listening right now is because
through the magic of YouTube social
media and all that we can bring to you
the differences and because it's up to
you you know it's what you put in your
head it's who your friends are what you
think all this stuff makes a difference
eventually so for most people they're
gonna make more money because the
government that's gonna pay them more to
stay at home that's socialist mmt modern
money theory theory that's socialism
that's Bernie Sanders that's fine well I
don't want that for me personally so the
best thing about it is is I don't have
to depend upon Wall Street for my asset
I can make my own I make my own ass is
like a book and I write a book let's say
I just wrote this book here this book is
sold to 50 publishers throughout the
world and they pay us let's say ten
thousand dollars for the right to
publish my book and they pay for the
publishing they pay for the printing
they just send me the check that's
called cash flow
that checkout by a real estate side out
to pay taxes that's the gate I think
that you really got to protect your
craft
you got to really concentrate on it
really put all of your energy into it um
learn as much as you can about the craft
and show no shame when you're out there
trying to go get it in other words you
know be willing to look foolish in order
to be great you know I'm saying
um don't know don't you know never be
ashamed to go for it you know and I'm
talking about in the right way like go
after that role that scares you go after
that opportunity that scares you go go
past you know any fear that you may feel
and go after you you know I'm saying so
that's what I was tell you and and that
goes for all others you know everybody
young out of any age you know I'm saying
I think that the idea of going after
your dreams is timeless you know I'm
saying
so yeah just remember that I if you want
more advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable and continue
to believe and I'll see you there when
the market crash in 2008 guess how much
money I borrowed